- I didn't get the job.
- In some countries, no
one's ever had a job.
Perspective.
- Stop!
You've participated
in a trolling cliche.
Have some perspective.
By using this attack
of equivalency,
a wise and sagely troll like
you can look down from on high
and neg away any discussion
you don't see as important.
Think reality TV's
rotting our brains?
Well, don't forget about
starving children in Somalia.
Did you just say
children in Somalia?
Well, you shouldn't compare
that to the conflict
in East Timor.
East Timor? Have
some perspective.
The sun will someday expand
and engulf our entire planet.
Well, this kind of logic is
the perfect way to ensure
that we never talk about
anything ever again,
which, actually, now that
we're thinking of it,
it's a great idea, specifically
as it pertains to you.
You don't care
about these issues.
You care about being right.
People are capable of
being upset about more than
one thing at a time.
For example, the person
you're watching right now
is upset about world
hunger, climate change,
and the fact that your
mother gave birth to you.
(hip hop music)